[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we were just caught talking on a talk
show never happened I want to make sure
we we get to this because you're here in
part to talk about this contest you're
doing with lathes lays the potato chip
people what's what's going on here
what's your connection with lays why
Lovelace yeah I know I'm part of their
you don't look like you eat a lot of
potatoes
I mean Lay's is part of the bigger
company called frito-lay but it I grew
up with every probably every product
they've ever had and the first guy I
ever kissed was eating Cheetos so I was
remember that and then must have been in
heaven and then you know the Lay's
potato chips they used to smash him in
my tuna sandwich and then I would take
that it would do that to I would crush
it potentially put them in my sandwich
and choke on them later yeah sister and
I we'd fight over Doritos we'd always
fight over that right which was the
cheesiest but so I'm part of do us a
flavor campaign so we're letting the
consumers pick the next great flavor of
the the bag of potato chips and they've
done this all over the world and this is
the first time we're doing it in the
United States and the winner gets 1
million dollars now you have our
attention 1% of the sales right oh
you're taking a bit of a risk there you
take the million dollars or a percentage
of the sale if you have a good flavor
but there's some crazy ones like in um
in Australia I think it's like Cajun
squirrel
wait cater squirrel was the winner yeah
how is called-- sports Australia they're
crazy yeah I know
that seems this cajun squirrel is the
number one ingredient that has been
submitted so far as bacon everybody
keeps submitting this half the audience
is holding bacon in their hands I defy
you to find a food that does not combine
well with bacon right everything tastes
good baby I'm wearing that you in the UK
or in Europe there was like builders
breakfast so the potato chip tasted like
eggs and bacon and everything on a
potato chip just so you have one chip in
the morning provides all the nutrients
we brought one this is a real this is a
real time we have one right here
which you guys brought what words what
countries is the winner in New Zealand
New Zealand okay this is Sunday roast
which is the crispy bits left in the pan
after you make a row so it's like the
drizzle and the grease now it's good
yeah I mean it the stuff that's left
over in the pan after you've you've
cooked a roast they scrape it off with a
knife and turn it into a potato chip
well you know we can recreate the flavor
literally eat anything right now
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you can go to Facebook backslash lays
and you can submit as many times as you
want that's right anyways do us a flavor
contest go to leis Facebook page by
October 6 and actually pretty good yeah
so nice to see you yeah and best of luck
with everything
eva longoria under the alma wars you're
my fellow latino/latina
we're very quiet ever seen Mexicans are
very close yes yes yes Catholic I'll be
there and I'll be hoping you chase the
noise I make around very attractively
me